the 10 last welcome wagon has arrived
[Music]
so you're heavily favored this weekend
you think this will end your
embarrassing streak of draws
lord i've never been embarrassed about
having streaks in my drawers you know
it's all part of growing
up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i got a question for you has a team like
us ever won the whole chimichanga
not for 40 years oh no you don't come
through here that's fine yeah i got you
it's like dukes of hazards
or y'all probably call it the earls of
risk over here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think it's time for these young fellas
to meet that guy oh no
let that's up
[Music]
all right you know turn birds start
touching your toes
they touch each other's toes what what
all that
how long was i not as long as last time
but nobody was hurt okay
[Music]
people saying there's something wrong
with us not the way i see it
i believe in communism rom communism
that is
if tom hanks meg ryan can go through
some heartfelt struggles and still end
up happy
then so can we
[Music]
this is our turn to make history and i
believe we're gonna do just that
the family we're born with and to
families we make along the way
to richmond right let's go kick their
butts
butts on three works for me one two
[Music]
three
you